[Music]
hey wisecrack
jared again like everyone else sometimes
i just need to laugh the pain away
often the crushing anxiety of existence
may feel like too much but
hey that's why i have a dog it helps
we at wisecrack love us to monty python
these wily brits redefined comedy in the
1970s and are still
hugely influential just look at comedies
today
south park rick and morty or even
deadpool all hilarious in their own
unique ways but without monty python
they probably wouldn't even exist
monty python paved the way for comedy as
we know it combining absurdity
satire and post-modern reflexivity into
some of the most influential and quoted
comedies ever
this is an x pattern
so because there's nothing funnier than
explaining a joke to death welcome to
this wisecrack edition on the legacy of
monty python oh and we'll be answering
your questions for the first hour in the
comments so
see you there part one post-modernism
like a hipster in a gluten-free juice
bar
post-modernism is everywhere these days
jurassic world star wars family guy
pretty much anything you can think of
these films and tv shows
constantly refer back to themselves
commenting on the narrative conventions
and iconography of their predecessors
it's another death star i wish that were
the case major this was the death star
and this is starkiller base or well
just copying them wholesale but nothing
encapsulates this movement more
than deadpool heck we even did an entire
philosophy of on this exact subject
everyone loves deadpool because quite
simply he doesn't give a [ __ ]
he's rebelliously self-aware repeatedly
winking at his own narrative and mocking
the superhero genre
okay let's pro con this superhero thing
this constant self-reflexivity
encapsulates post-modernism
first coined by the french philosopher
jean-francois leotard in 1979
for leotard all stories previously told
fit into oftold
grand mythologies great heroes on a
voyage for some grandiose goal
or as he referred to them metanarratives
for leotard these meta-narratives were
stories that provided a pattern and
structure for people's beliefs
teaching viewers a universal insight
think of the wizard of oz and how when
you strip it of all the flying monkeys
and melting witches it's actually just a
story about a girl realizing that
there's no place like home or
even the fast and the furious underneath
all the ludicrous car stunts there's a
deeper meta-narrative about the
importance of family
through these stories morals and social
customs are taught and reinforced
but postmodernism subverts these grand
narratives revealing the chaos and
disorder beneath
like say deadpool a comic book character
who constantly tears down everything
that comic books stand
for you're probably thinking my
boyfriend said this was a superhero
movie but that guy in the red suit just
turned that other guy into a
kebab but as edgy as deadpool may seem
he ain't got sh on the pythons who took
postmodern deconstruction to a
whole other level case in point their
all-time classic
monty python and the holy grail whereas
deadpool lampoons only the comic book
meta-narrative
monty python and the holy grail is
defined by breaking down
multiple metanarratives among them
arthurian chivalry
christianity logic and the very medium
of film itself
the first of these metanarratives
arthurian chivalry first evolved in the
late middle ages
idealizing knights as honorable and
self-sacrificing
you know the usual nightly like
protecting the weak
showing mercy to enemies never lying and
championing truth and justice
but monty python and the holy grail
completely dismantles and mocks these
time-tested tenants
who's that i don't know that's big king
why he hasn't got [ __ ] all over him when
sarabin encounters a three-headed giant
his minstrels sing the heroic narrative
that everyone expects bolts are robin
brought forth from camelot he was not
afraid to die for braves
but robin himself runs the hell away as
quickly as possible
similarly in the arthurian legend
arthur's arrival at camelot is usually
treated as an emotional
high point in his story camelot camelot
camelot yet monty python undercuts the
seriousness of the moment
turning this hallmark event into a goofy
musical number
and then to top it off arthur decides
not to even bother going to camelot no
on second thoughts let's not go to
camelot it is a silly place
each of our supposed great heroes are
revealed to be far
less than they claim the power hungry
arthur demands that every peasant
acknowledge him as their king
does he think he is i'm your king well i
didn't vote for you
but if they dare question his rule he
immediately attacks them
come and see the violence inherent in
the system help help i'm being repressed
bloody peasant oh what a giveaway did
you hear that jewelry that i
that's what i'm on about sergala had the
pure the most faithful of knights is
seduced in less than
four minutes by a company of 160 lonely
women
and when lancelot receives a note from a
distressed maiden he rushes to rescue
her
but in the process murders dozens of
unarmed people
then in the end it turns out there
wasn't even a maiden to save in the
first place
thing is i thought your son was a lady i
can understand that monty python uses
post-modernism to illustrate how the
stories people tell themselves enable
some awful sh
lancelot and arthur's own metanarratives
justifying their violent and oppressive
acts
the fact that these meta-narratives
aren't even true to begin with is just
the icing on the cake
as our nightly heroes are revealed to be
cowards hypocrites and violent
sociopaths
you see what i mean i just get carried
away i'm really just awfully sorry sorry
sorry everyone even god is put into
doubt per the christianity metanarrative
god is good and all-powerful and has a
plan for humanity
yet in monty python and the holy grail
god isn't great and kind at all
he's just a cranky dick who's really
crappily animated
philosopher mikhail bachton defined this
as the downward swing
which i swear isn't a baseball term for
backtin
most stories are upward swings in that
they elevate a story to a symbolic state
and make them universal
on the contrary in a downward swing the
classical story becomes
so distorted and grotesque that you
don't even know whether to scream
cry or laugh and it's not just the story
that becomes distorted but also we
the readers and viewers ourselves every
lesson we learned through the
metanarrative is now cast into doubt
right alongside it
take one of the most famous scenes in
the holy grail the witch trial
sir bedover the wise puts a poor woman
through a
foolproof logic test in order to
determine if she's a witch her bedavir
which is burn at the stake just like
wood and wood floats on water just like
a duck
so if the woman is a witch she will
weigh the same as the duck monty python
here takes formal logic and distorts it
into a grotesque version of itself in
effect casting doubt on our own
fundamental faith and logic
if classical logic can be distorted into
justifying a woman's death
then how can it be truly trusted at all
by the end of the holy grail this
distortion extends to the very film
itself
as arthur prepares for an epic battle
with the french at castle ard
modern day police suddenly arrive and
arrest the king for murder the police
then push and cover the camera lens
breaking the fourth wall making the
audience cognizant of the fact they're
watching a movie
the holy grail constantly pokes fun at
itself for being a movie
for instance the film's title credits
are undermined when swedish subtitles
suddenly appear
promoting the country as a terrific
vacation spot the credit makers are then
promptly fired
causing the credit format to completely
change throughout the film arthur uses
coconuts instead of a horse
due to the film's tight budget and later
arthur even refers to one character as
there's the old man from scene 24 and
just to hammer the point home
the knights defeat the legendary black
beast of arg not through any battle
or test of wills but because the
animator that designed the creature has
a heart attack
this self-reflectivity reveals the holy
grail to be its own metanarrative
film just as artificial as the
chivalrous arthurian heroes within do
you think this scene should have been
cut
we were so worried when the boys were
writing it but now we're glad
it's better than some of the previous
scenes i think that's just how
post-modern monty python in the holy
grail truly is
it deconstructs religion and logic
within a deconstruction of heroic tropes
within a deconstruction of the film
medium itself
basically the inception of postmodern
film
part 2 the comedy of the absurd there's
probably no show as popular on the
interwebs as rick and morty
i mean be honest wisecrack's really just
a domain switch away from becoming a
rick and morty fan club
and that's because the show always ties
its absurd humor with thought-provoking
insight
like well on the meaninglessness of life
yes
you god not today [ __ ] take the get
schwifty episode
when massive heads suddenly appear all
across the planet many people begin to
worship the heads as gods
starting up a cult and even sacrificing
people to appease them
of course in reality these heads aren't
gods at all
but an alien race that just wants earth
to participate in an american idol-like
reality show
this type of humor is known as the
comedy of the absurd
this existential base comedy focuses on
the fallout when confronted with a world
devoid of meaning
however instead of wallowing in some
murky woes me despair
the absurd takes the opposite approach
pointing out the broad
humor and our own tragic insignificance
this tragic absurdity is foundational to
monty python's brand of humor
and their third feature the life of
brian poor brian's entire existence is
one
big absurd misunderstanding the humble
peasant is born in the stable next to
jesus
confusing the three wise men who assumed
the not special at all brian to be the
messiah
he's the son of god our messiah king of
the jews
that's capricorn is it the projection of
significance on the insignificant is a
hallmark of existential thought
in particular our boy albert camus who
rejected this desperate search for
meaning and instead embraced
the you guessed it absurd when brian
runs away from his disciples they
mistakenly believe he's risen to heaven
and later when brian loses a sandal
these same disciples proclaim the sandal
his sign
of course brian didn't mean for the
sandal to be anything more than footwear
and yet
people in their desire for meaning
attribute significance to even the
silliest of objects it
is his guard we will carry it for you
master
we see this exact same misappropriation
of meaning in get swifty as principal
vagina and the rest of his cult mistake
the alien heads as gods
when actually their only reality tv show
junkies
comedies of the absurd draw their humor
from this discrepancy between what is
and what isn't between what's true and
what people believe to be true
characters in these absurd comedies are
often caught in hopeless situations
forced into repetitive and ultimately
fruitless actions
like brian who constantly tries to tell
his disciples he's not the messiah
but too little avail only the true
messiah denies his divinity
no matter what brian does his disciples
grow in number and become
ever more fervent all leading to a
horrific and tragic conclusion
crucifixion yet despite his impending
doom
brian's comforted by his fellow
crucifixion buddies who break out into
song
always look on the bright side of life
the crucifixion buddy's cheerful lament
reflects the myth of sisyphus
in which poor sisyphus is cursed to roll
a rock up a mountain
only for it to fall back down over and
over again
camus famously applied the greek myth to
life itself
the trick though is not to let this
meaninglessness ever get you down
instead in the words of life of brian
always look at the bright side
because when faced with our own
insignificance and impending doom
there's only one real option though it
may seem completely
absurd laughter part 3 political satire
nowadays satire has become more vital
than ever
whether via late night talk shows like
full frontal with samantha b
or more traditional half-hour comedies
like south park hell the last three
seasons of south park focused heavily on
the 2016 election and the trump
presidency
i don't give two [ __ ] about a treaty
you're a polish [ __ ] political satires
like south park derive their humor by
revealing the hypocrisy in established
rules and orders
a lot of the 2016 election and the pc
brigade but
way before south park monty python paved
the way
subverting the established political
ideologies of england in fact south park
creators trey parker and matt stone
often
cite monty python as the single biggest
influence on their show
matt and i met and got along so well
because we were just
pure python freaks in monty python's
final
and darkest feature the meaning of life
the pythons openly comment on english
imperialism
economic disparity and the classes
social hierarchies of the country
the opening mini-movie the crimson
permanent assurance depicts a group of
poor elderly workers forced into a
pirate-like frenzy by young american
yuppies
the old workers rebel against these
yuppie dicks throwing them out windows
to their death and then proceed to
destroy
every shiny bright corporate building in
their path bringing down the system that
literally anchored them to the ground
the pythons carry this satirical look at
capitalism throughout the film
questioning the economic notion that
self-interest results in the greater
good
in fact we see quite the opposite in the
sketch the miracle of birth the doctors
are far
more concerned with their fancy
equipment and impressing their
administrator than the poor woman
they're operating on
and get the most expensive machines in
case the administrator comes later in
the sketch live organ transplants
two bureaucrats forcefully remove the
liver from an impoverished man for the
good of the country
remarking nonsensically that they must
kill the guy so that they can then take
his liver
they all go to saving lives madam
constantly we see
people drowning under this system
britain's yorkshire is ironically
referred to as a third world country
and in the same sketch a poor man is
forced to sell off his children to
science in order to make ends meet
this economic disparity climaxes in the
sketch the autumn years where the
grotesquely obese and rich mr creosote
dines at a fancy restaurant eating more
and more
until he literally explodes
the implications couldn't be clear the
rich get richer and fatter
at the expense of the starving lower
class but it's not just
social injustice that the python skewer
but the whole notion of british
imperialism in general
the hand of god strikes down a military
officer who insists
britain will always need an army to put
down differing ideologies
and in the same sketch a sergeant major
drills his platoon on whether they have
anything better to do than march up and
down the town square
well it turns out they do well to be
quite honest sarge i'd rather be at home
with the wife and kids
would you now yes sarge
right off you go like read a book or go
to the movies or
really anything at all the pythons even
state this central thesis at the end of
the picture
try and be nice to people avoid eating
fat read a good book every now and then
get some walking in
and try and live together in peace and
harmony with people of all creeds and
nations
for the pythons british imperialism is a
threat to the meaning of life
this manifests in their depiction of war
where soldiers attempting to celebrate a
birthday are gunned down
one by one the brutal reality of war of
supposed imperial conquest
juxtaposed against the simple pleasure
of enjoying a birthday cake
these ideas extend to their sketch show
the flying circus the show often
portrays bureaucrats as buffoons
or as sticks in the mud constantly
censoring the show itself
i'm not prepared to pursue my line of
inquiry any further as i think this is
getting too silly
quite agree quite a bit silly silly
silly right
get on with it get on with it
as christopher hitchens once said the
essential founding gag of monty python
is the bubbling magma of absurdity that
lay beneath the fragile crust of british
reserve
at any moment a man with a bowler hat or
an umbrella might become a raging
cross-dresser or barking sadist
it's this unpredictability this mixture
between the postmodern the political and
the absurd that makes monty python
unlike
any comedy troupe that came before or
after by merging together social
commentary
existential angst and just plain old
silliness the pythons always keep you on
your toes
they defied convention concocting a
brand of comedy
so singular that a word has been created
just for them
python-esque today their brand of humor
permeates every facet of the comedic
landscape
as always thanks for watching guys peace
so
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
you